1999 une petite nouvelle fait son
apparition sur la scène du rap français
merci d'être venus apprécier et goûter
critiqué observé nom de scène diam's la
rappeuse n'a que 18 ans et vient de
sortir son premier album ça
qu'aujourd'hui pour moi le rap soit un
message et faut qu'il soit perçu de la
façon dont tu veux qu'ils soient perçus
james tente de s'imposer dans un milieu
réputé viril elle essaie de se faire une
place aux côtés d'une autre rappeuse
bams c'est vrai que les débuts du rap
féminin
point de vue distri promis quoi promo ça
a été bien fait distrib peut-être pas
mais il faut peut-être pas mettre tous
sur cotés sur côtés ça tient au rap
féminin c'est peut-être que chaque chose
en son temps et des débuts sont toujours
plus difficiles 2003 brut de femme son
deuxième album et un carton est grave à
la bourre mais elle est là diam's
deux cent mille copies vendues dans ses
chansons diam's fait passer des messages
les jeunes la banlieue mais aussi les
violences conjugales tout y passe j'ai
eu le désir d'en parler simplement pour
informer les gens que les violences
conjugales ne sont pas forcément des
violences subies par les adultes que
c'est parfois aussi quand notre premier
amour et toutes ces petites choses là en
2004 un an plus tard c'est la
consécration diam's
elle triomphe aux victoires de la
musique avec le meilleur album rap et
c'est pas fini 2006 l'idole des ados va
encore plus haut
dans ma bulle son troisième album se
vend à plus de huit cent mille
exemplaires au total quinze chansons
dont celle ci devenue culte
[Musique]
la boulette le titre est un fervent
plaidoyer pour la jeunesse diam's une
porte parole de la génération d'un an
l'année 2008 marque un tournant pour la
rappeuse diam's tombe en dépression mais
ça n'empêche pas de sortir un quatrième
et dernier album en 2009 sos 200000
exemplaires vendus un album confessions
écouter quelques notes du titre enfants
du désert dans cette course au succès je
crois que l'on côtoie l'enfer
ma soeur mon frère on est aussi des
enfants du dessert
on a tous un rôle à jouer sur terre
sorti aujourd'hui le rap c'est terminé
pour diam's en 2022 douze ans après la
fin de sa carrière diam's fait son
retour dans la lumière elle est présente
au festival de cannes pas de nouvel
album mais un documentaire intitulé
salam centré sur sa vie et qu'elle vient
présenter en plus de l'avoir écrit elle
a aussi co réalisé
[Musique]